alors benjamin andré à merci d'être là
merci à vous merci ans de la merci à
vous avez ces trois cachetées trois
affirmations sur benjamin castaldi
vous avez vu et il y en a une qui est
vrai on va essayer de trouver laquelle
est généralement quand on l'a dit un
truc c'est souvent très frais alors
c'est frais et très près si c'est une
catastrophe
c'est pas la peine non non non non ça
peut être une catastrophe aussi par une
petite catastrophe gens vous allez avoir
un panaris ou un truc comme ça c'est là
dans la fois lundi qu'il allait boire du
coca c'est ballot allez il est bien
cassée quand même où la croix
d'information c'est votre cadeau
d'anniversaire au regard des lots bien
ça fait très plaisir
46 benjamin déjà tu vois tu as passé
trois mois difficiles là c'était pas
facile mais maintenant c'est terminé
à partir du 1er avril toutes les portes
s'ouvrent et ça y est on file à queue
pour toujours à 6011 à gros contrats
signés pour une chaîne nationale et
c'est quelque chose qui va commencer on
va dire début 2020 un gros contrat
signer 7 9 ans suis désolé peut-être que
tout le monde suit on sait pas mais déjà
on sait qu'un gros contrats pour toi ça
c'est déjà un contrat confiant ça tu vas
kinect darty
[Rires]
l'impact de ce bail ya une signature de
notaire là avant lui - en fait la croix
son vrai là ah ben oui en fait c'était
pas du tout ce qu'on avait prévu
il devait y avait des fautes graves
donné que du break j'ai dit au coin de
rue sont rien ne marche aujourd'hui il
ne rencontrera pas dire aga khan n'a pas
nié au talent à manger les chaînes
ballon l'autre les rideaux c'est
n'importe quoi
jusque là seuls l'ouvreur audois drôme
où diana chaque maison et chaque
nouvelle maison il ya une nouvelle c'est
le sait bien c'est que du bonheur du
bonheur dans la journée je vous reviens
maintenant maison à contres à une maison
témoin vous êtes sûr que c'est benjamin
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
en fait elle est excellente la clape en
bas d un truc elle est réelle mais la
patrouille à la patouille les saucissons
et nettoyer pas dans deux arrêts hier
inquiétez pas on n'a pas besoin de
toucher les saucisses devant tout le
monde demande à beinheim